beaucoup de sujets discutés avec
stéphane marion ce soir économiste et
stratège en chef de la banque nationale
bonsoir alors comment s'explique d'abord
et avant tout stéfane marion le
mouvement boursier d'aujourd'hui c'est
une chose mais on sent du mouvement
depuis quelques temps déjà mouvement de
nervosité sur le nasdaq depuis quelques
temps
comment comme on l'expliqué la bourse
des gens très bien fait depuis le début
la nive niveau mondial plus de chalets
monsieur fillion ça fait longtemps qu'il
n'ya pas eu une correction de 10% faut
remonter ou à l'automne 2020 donc la
bourse très bien fait vous savez ce sont
des marchés de l'anticipation et on sait
que les résultats de les bénéfices des
entreprises sont extraordinaires au
premier trimestre là on est en train
d'être positionné pour la deuxième
moitié d'année
et comme vous l'avez mentionné qu allah
ya certaines inquiétudes par rapport au
politique monétaire advenant une
croissance qui serait plus fort que
prévu mais qui pourrait amener plus
d'inflation et doit peut-être une
révision niveau des taux d'intérêt et
pour le nasdaq en particulier s'étonner
dit ce qui est particulièrement
vulnérable aux remontées de taux
d'intérêt et on s'appuie beaucoup sur le
taux dépargne notamment qui est quand
même élevé
quand on regarde le taux dépasse aux
états unis au canada notamment au
royaume uni en espagne en allemagne en
france mais particulièrement au canada
royaume uni etats unis les taux
dépensons sont élevées si cette épargne
ne se transforme en dépenses de
consommation ça pourrait pousser
l'inflation à la hausse non et voilà le
principal défi des banques centrales
quel sera le rendement les ménages dans
un environnement post pandémique où les
gens se remettent à dépenser pour les
services des voyages et c'est donc le
graphique auquel vous faites allusion se
sont pas dit ce sont des paris
excédentaires donc jamais dans une dans
un cycle économique on s'est retrouvé
avec autant d'epargne excédentaire qui
est attribuable aux transferts
gouvernementaux qui ont été très
généreux dans plusieurs pays de l' ocde
donc la question de l'heure pour les
banques centrales
se pourrait-il que les ménages se
comportent plus agressive manquons pas
qu'on pense de façon à dépenser plus
fortement réduire l'épargné excédentaire
ce qui pourrait entraîner plus
d'inflation dans comme on nous parle
les marchés sont positionnés pour une
inflation qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 4%
cet été aux états unis et ensuite
s'estomper mais tout ça dépendra du
comportement des consommateurs et je
peux vous dire monsieur fillion c'est
l'inquiétude des marchés
il n'y a pas de modèle économique qui
sont calibrés pour savoir comment le
consommateur se comportera dans un
environnement post pandémie mais est ce
concert on s'attend quand même poussée
d'inflation qui sera très très
temporaire quelques mois seulement si le
charnier aussi le scénario de base des
banques centrales c'est la raison pour
laquelle les banques centrales se disent
prêtes à maintenir les taux d'intérêt
relativement bas
la surprise pourrait venir des dépenses
de consommation plus agressive et si on
verra au cours des prochains mois moi je
pense qu'il faut pas il faut pas devenir
trop un négatif par rapport à l'économie
mondiale faut pas oublier monsieur
fillion que oui on épargne excédentaire
mais qu'en même temps il y
fameux transferts gouvernementaux qui
deviendront de moins en moins généreux
à mesure que l'été se déroulera donc moi
je pense que l'inflation pourrait aller
à près de 4% c'est eugénie pour ensuite
revenir autour de 2.5 pour ça s'il
s'avérait que ça demeure plus fort que
saab à ce moment l'un des marchés
pourrait devenir plus inquiet parce que
ça voudrait dire des banques centrales
qui devront changer leurs discours nous
amène sur les ressources stéfane marion
et les matériaux minéraux on observe des
records pour le cuivre et le fer
pourquoi l'économie mondiale
tellement bien moment où on se parle la
reprise généralisée je sais que les gens
sont inquiets par rapport à la présence
de variants ont certains pays émergents
dont line mais la réalité c'était
données économiques elles sont robustes
s'est généralisé dans l'ensemble
l'économie mondiale dont les pays
émergents et ce qui porte à croire que
la deuxième moitié d'année sera bonne et
comme co2 comme croissance mais le prix
des commodités et en os
d'autant plus que les taux d'intérêt
sont extrêmement bas au mans ce parc est
que le dollar américain se déprécie est
ce que tout ça
on voit le pétrole aussi qui monte en ce
moment est-ce qu'il faut additionner les
enjeux sur les pipelines dont on parlait
en début d'émission que ce soit au
michigan que ce soit le coloniaux pour
faire pression à la hausse sur le prix
du pétrole d'éventuellement sur le prix
de l'essence mais ce stade à 100 parce
que vous mentionnez de l'augmentation du
prix des commodités va faire monter le
coût des intrants pour plusieurs
compagnies il se pourrait que ça se
traduise par une augmentation des
niveaux du consommateur et ce qui est
agaçant au niveau du pipeline c'est que
ça ça en rajoute au niveau de
l'incertitude
puis vous savez je me rappelle une
époque pas si lointaine nous avions fait
une autre vue ensemble et on disait que
90% du pétrole québécois provenait du
moyen-orient ou d'afrique ce qui mettait
en péril la sécurité d'approvisionnement
du québec et on a tout changé les
pipelines ont été inversés soit près de
50% de la production de pétrole
consommation pétrole québécoise provient
des états unis hélas si on ferme le
pipeline qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est ce
qu'on doit se réapprovisionner par pète
royer sur le golfe saint laurent
c'est beaucoup de questions et ce à un
crédit à court terme plus d'augmentation
au niveau du consommateur pour le prix
décembre et donc est ce que ça relance
par ailleurs le débat sur nrj est à
intéressant comme question je pense qu'à
court terme il faut trouver une solution
avec le michigan puis n'oubliez pas
n'oubliez pas que présentement et c'est
ce qu'on vend rien versé le pipeline qui
avait été un exercice un peu agaçant
mais il faut se poser comme question
comme canadiens comme québécois de dire
est ce que la sécurité nationale fait en
sorte qu'on doit repenser ce projet là
je pense que c'est des bons sujets à
discussion pour nos politiciens au cours
des prochains trimestres au niveau est
connue ou trouver une solution ça va
être un bon débat aussi pour notre c'est
un petit peu plus tard dans l'émission
merci beaucoup stéphane mario roy pour
voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh